ce nouveau tgv reliera paris à marseille
en trois heures seulement
la sncf a dû former un personnel
hautement qualifié
car la conduite du train n'est pas
automatique elle demande une extrême
vigilance et une bonne connaissance de
la ligne reportage patrick esther est
bonne on verra pour pouvoir créer une
centaine de liaisons tgv chaque jour sur
la ligne nouvelle méditerranée marseille
la sncf a dû former 500 nouveaux
conducteurs des hommes qui maîtrise
parfaitement la technique du pilotage à
grande vitesse c'est que contrairement
aux idées reçues le tgv n'est pas un
train automatique
c'est une machine qui nécessite une
vigilance de tous les instants pour le
technicien seul aux commandes dans la 4g
en voulant je suis obligée de manoeuvrer
sur levier
je ne peux pas leur arracher plus de
deux secondes et demi
deux ans et demi on va l'entendre une
sonnerie si je ne réagis pas
il ya la coupure du courant et l'arrêt
automatique par le panache de gens je
n'ai plus de signalisation extérieure ce
sont des fréquences dans le rail sont
captés par la machine décrypter et qui
me sont visualisées ici en chiffrant
km/heure donc à l'heure actuelle j'ai 2
170 km/heure d'afficher vos cabine ce
que l'on appelle le cap signal il peut
changer à toutes les secondes à tout
moment donc il faut être très vigilant
et le surveillant en permanence un
conducteur de tgv doit connaître par
coeur toutes les côtes et toutes les
descentes de la ligne pour anticiper les
réactions du train afin de freiner ou
d'accélérer le moins possible ainsi sur
un trajet de 2h les moteurs ne
fonctionne guère plus mr le reste c'est
de la roue libre sur l'élan pour
réaliser les records de vitesse comme
ici 515 km heure les conducteurs
deviennent de véritables pilotes d'essai
leur frein roule deux fois plus vite
qu'un airbus au décollage pourtant même
lorsqu ils testent une voie de nouvelles
à 350 kilomètres heure comme au mois de
janvier entre valence et avignon
ces sommes restent d'une grande modestie
incontestablement non l'objet devient
familier
engagé avec du pays
toutes les personnes qui ont participé à
la mise en oeuvre du projet dans son
exécution de
et c'est ce même conducteur qui réalise
actuellement laissées d'endurance entre
calais et marcel 1000 km en moins de
quatre heures le seul maître à bord
après dieu